this week we've got art in the air
holographic wife and disgusting cake
that's a birthday cake bark on let it go
let it go it's that the cake was it
ice cream cake oh that's not the story
and that's why I don't buy her a cake
the last three years other people buy it
and she kills it they won't do it
David kill the T but the case birthday
that was me that's because in bottle and
horror birthday yeah
rent Oh TIFF is a better husband than
you are yep oh yeah dude let's get
married if I mean if it doesn't work out
here for sure cuz you're way better than
keep you two cuz you help keep you all
the time okay we just suck each other's
dicks already dude we just were even so
uh alright looks like we gotta suck each
other's dicks Casey you got a 77 or l7
the Marine Corps the Marine Corps yes
the Marine Corps they're investigating
these pilots I heard about them Oh what
happened was just a brain court Oh
who's heard about the very car the t-34
sea crew is being in fact I thought she
said the T is me too me too I was right
okay okay well this what's the t-34
secret they're being investigated for a
flying pattern that resembles an obscene
image its day do they do that so it has
to be a dick it's called it's kind of
your day it's dick involved that's so
tight
imagine going up a joint to skis like
you're breaking the sound barrier and
he's just like on projects the precision
that's looking good they should get
awarded what's the problem now the funny
thing is the radar person's watching it
oh my god so they're doing all of this
just for the radar person bad shoe that
there's an Instagram photo that the
radar person took know how much money
that dick probably cost oh that's
probably like five hundred million
dollars like jet fuel is [ __ ]
expensive why he's just it's like the
minute they take off it's a thousand
dollars a minute probably you think they
had to speed dry could you do that I
mean I don't know does the pilot jet
pilots have extreme precision I can't
even do that with that [ __ ] it just
got [ __ ] yeah I'd like to do that with
the car on the open field like nice
tight turns like they don't even bother
what was he doing down there
he was just like [ __ ] the Salton Sea
Base they must be air donuts
that's dog yeah over the Salton Sea he
haven't lined the tip yeah really did
love it oh if I'd thought the Salton Sea
was a vagina too so I'm a perfectly
placed as penis well I'm glad someone
like this type of precision is defendant
country meets here that's what a lot of
people are saying they're like well if
you guys tell him like that don't fire
him yeah so they're two pilots that have
been grounded water
like literally grounded that's so cute
yeah so they are they can't they can't
fly but they're still doing ground
support so I think I should show them
the movie Top Gun
because maverick is quite the renegade
but he's also really good yeah so this
is not the first time that US pilots
have been grounded for like creating a
watch Top Gun fall
yes the knee but where they got it from
I know there was this aircrew who flew a
Navy warplane in the shape of a penis
above Washington last year this air art
is that what we're talking about
but the Navy tweeted it out yeah maybe
time time oh my gosh that's funny
it says Brooke I love humor dude the
drawing dicks is so funny did I mention
it before tits and chi chi's my [ __ ]
Japanese teacher in high school she was
trying to draw a subway and like how
people would enter into the subway so
you could enter from here and here so it
was the bullet train thing and then she
drew circle right here and she cut it
like when the [ __ ] cockpit it yeah
dude ears laughing I wouldn't die she
know she was wrong she didn't know
that's why everybody was cracking up she
know what's going on so she was laughing
to uh do a huge dick on the [ __ ]
whiteboard dude do you ever see that one
about the music or like the weather
person someone yeah like they
accidentally did it cuz like this finger
kind of like the line it's amazing how
easy it is to accidentally draw a penis
how many times have you done it several
well I think it's because there's such a
wide array of genitalia that that you
could say that looks like a penis and
this may look completely different but
we know that it also does look like a
dick so phallic symbols are all over the
world yeah and there's a wide range of
fallacies you're right you know a lot of
great inventions happen because guys
think about dick and [ __ ] all day
like what like the missile like an arrow
popsicle like a popsicle I thought you
were gonna say like a flashlight do it
like physics and just what could cut
through there as it something to do with
physical attraction it all came because
guys were thinking about busting nuts
and dicks make them arrows projectiles
if you could fly one of these jets what
would you draw in the
I'm follow the rules whatever is not
gonna pass although throw up in square
square I don't know I just like a little
90-degree turns I don't have you guys
ever gone in one of those like jet
seamen simulator they what are they
called
I don't know just simulators yeah that I
got in one of those before and I felt
like I needed to throw up cuz I thought
I would love it cuz you know I like
adrenaline [ __ ] but I could not stand it
it's different when you hit G's like
lateral G's and you don't shift like
when your organs start moving couple
inches to the right or to the left
that shit's crazy [ __ ] that excuse me
yeah well they hit G's in the end the
Jets like they're hitting like 3 G's 4
G's whatever I like when you watch video
and when your lip is now over here
you're turning really [ __ ] fast yeah
it's like you're always in the elevator
going down really fast times like a
thousand yeah kill you isn't it I saw a
video the other day of a kid oh it was a
kid that was on one of those spinny
merry-go-round things you can spin it
how did they spin it they took an
electric scooter and put it like under
the thing that's done and so it was
spinning really fast no the kid actually
almost died from the g-forces all of the
blood went into his brain and they
thought that they and all the kids left
oh that's fun yeah they liked her I saw
that the other day that [ __ ] was wild
all like g-forces so you're talking
about my organs over here over there
let's keep them ready right about that
roller coaster that's designed to kill
you yeah and it's got like 10 g-forces
absolutely I was very clear it's
designed to kill you yeah it's like a
it's like a euthanasia oh my god come
die on this roller coaster designed by
the time they finish everyone's [ __ ]
mm-hmm fun has way to die though
I rather just die in my sleep I do
roller coasters in gentle-like - oh
you're one of those I'll do it I'll do
it
Geo I'll do it I love her look but
she'll come pulling the whole way
through oh yeah absolutely
like I'll be silent not getting lying
I'll act like you know like bad [ __ ]
you can't kill me you know and then when
we actually get on it and it starts
going up and they're like are you good
I'm like yeah I'm good don't talk to me
right now just don't talk the music
starts getting louder going up the [ __ ]
they got me on some roller coaster one
time they were playing Metallica I was
like this is not a good sign yeah yeah
what are they play like Enter Sandman
yeah and then they played like heartbeat
though because they have yes they do
that right by your ear and then towards
the end I wouldn't know since we got to
go we have the good smell of theme park
rollercoasters like before you get on
the [ __ ] thing and then the smell of
the tracks you know I'm talking about
you don't you don't know what that
smells like
alright so next time pay attention to
this smell I only smell like popcorn and
like just it smells like that too but
there's also like a like a special our
entire venom smell yeah and then you
could really smell it at Pirates of the
Caribbean like well that's different
reserves water there that's one two but
then like in line you could smell it and
there's just there's just a
rollercoaster smell like the machine and
then yeah I love that smell I can kind
of like smell it in my nose the only
thing I smell is like perspiration cuz I
would be sweating in the line just
pouring buckets of sweat trying to act
cool keeping up with other driving you
could smell really good when you're at
the top but I blacked out by that and in
that I don't do anything with Heights
like I can't I can't [ __ ] with Heights
that's right like roller coasters is not
my [ __ ] thing like I had done roller
coasters in the past but the last time I
did one I had like a very sharp pain
like in my heart oh yeah no more and
also - I get like vertigo so I started
meds that you were
having a great time no that means I was
[ __ ] dying and I couldn't get off
that [ __ ] rollercoaster alright next
story here this Japanese man married a
hologram not that wild to me anymore
Japan has just gotten the [ __ ]
loneliness to another level yeah so this
but they're happy about it they're fine
but some of these guys I think people
don't understand that they're like
LARPers they're like they're playing
into it some of them aren't a thousand
percent serious they're just like
playing the role so like it's like it's
like a real-life troll
that's like oh yeah I know I'm [ __ ]
around but then like I'm just gonna live
it up so he vowed to like never marry
anyone because there was this woman a
co-worker of his that at one point drove
him to a nervous breakdown and like he
was always bullied in school because he
was like a nerd or geek or whatever and
so girls would always bully him be like
Oh get away from here
that sucks well one day they said to him
when he was in their locker room is that
all females bother he's like he's like
looking through the peephole what I'm
saying he poked me and I wanna bully
thirty-five-year-old he has been living
with this talking hologram of Miku know
Hatsune Miku I don't know that is what
it looks like this look like a developer
or something like using a program [ __ ]
this device here is worth a little bit
less than $3,000 and it's in his home
just a cheap wife yep yeah and then he
also had like a little ceremony and
invited about 40 people who's no none of
his family members showed up I just want
to know why why do they have to get
married why not just why can't you just
be happy because he always wanted to be
married tax but he wanted to have a
ceremony because he's saying that he
actually had this entire ceremony to be
sort of an inspiration for other people
that have married this we're not an
inspiration to anybody dude because the
company that created her
they've initiated what is it 3700
uninitiated issued they issued more than
3700 certificates for cross dimension
marriage marriages cross the convention
that's next level cross dementia
intergalactic marriage inner dimension
an urge amendment even took the dog to
get her ring size
this is embarrassing dolly to get the
ring size I would I don't know if I I
think I just slap him
but like think about the follow-up
article in five years when he gets born
he gets divorced because that the newer
version of her come hmm he gets divorces
and he cheated on her with another one
that's the emotional turmoil that a man
has to go through after cheating on his
cyber wife dad I want to watch that I
want to read every article that I want
to see him being like guilty like this
she's like we're worried today oh no
we're yeah that gives me texture when
he's on her way when he stopped no Dan
that's all that's what have you started
spending more time at the arcade and
[ __ ] they have an argument you're always
over there playing video games that's
like their version of his ship Oh that'd
be so weird so you like watching chun-li
huh you'd be she's so [ __ ] hot I'm
shutting down he spent 2 million yen on
the wedding which is no so he got money
that has me all administrator hey troll
or he's got really bad social anxiety
and emotional probably back extent day
he was like it's easier for me to do
this than to work out my problems with
you know a female yes people who just
don't want to be human yeah they just
think that everything is supposed to
work out a hundred percent yeah you got
to work for [ __ ] in this world yeah and
it's so much more fulfilling to like
date somebody and have your problems and
your trials and tribulations like it
feels like pain in the moment but it's
worth it and patches are what make
relationships get stronger well n is a
yeah feelings is what makes you a person
y'all ever seen that episode of black
mirror was she like were her her
boyfriend dies and she gets the robot
bridge yeah yeah yeah Oh more I love it
was that like he was perfect and just
said yes to everything and she didn't
want that she wanted something more
human like I want you to argue with me I
wanna have a few problems here and there
like I want to know this is real I think
in that black man episode I was so
jealous though I was like I love that
[ __ ] version you're a spicy
[ __ ] and you like spicier kimchi
kimchi maybe I need to change myself
dude that's what he said none of your
got like friends that are none of your
friends are non spicy like name me a
friend that you have that way I'm pretty
bland I am oh my god you were a banana
relaxing like they have this fire like
they like to argue in ruffle feathers
and not me I'm like water ha ha ha shut
the [ __ ] up
yeah you're [ __ ] sewage water bro I'm
a piece poop oh the gross cake how can
cake be gross is it like mm-hmm garlic
flavor what it's made out of [ __ ] that
$8 [ __ ] Vons cake
that shit's like I seems like this thick
just don't eat the buck
I like those like the $5 can come out
the [ __ ] one with the ice is hella
overly sweet hell yeah the coconut ones
really then the cake part is always
really dry yeah it's dry that's what
this is for key in general like it's
even the best cake ever or it [ __ ]
sucks I've never had a bad cake in my
life you know what I'm noticing though
batter even like cake we both didn't
grow up on cake like my birthday cake
was a watermelon
cuz I couldn't eat a lot of like milk
products yeah so my taste buds when it
comes to those kind of products is not
the most fun because you yeah I did you
put but I don't even I hate cakes you
hate cats
I hate cakes I think they're nasty but
in that category I eat all of them
they're bomb
got a bull it's not a real hate
relationship like for example like if I
go to the bakery or a pastry shop
whatever I'd rather get a pie I rather
get like some sort of flaky croissant
type thing like out of all the baked
goods cake is bottom feeder [ __ ] for me
I don't even want to eat that but if you
bring it in would you eat this cake nice
transition so this Baker she was asked
to make this baby shower cake for a
customer sister that's what a [ __ ] up
and a cake showing a baby being born
it's all its glory
so is it like so this is Rebecca Baker
Rebecca is okay do you guys good
squeamish look away right now ready yes
and like blood and hair and like this
[ __ ] on the kids yeah well everything
but the baby head she might send them a
progress picture and she this exactly
like they were so happy when they got
the kid good though I don't know why
she'd even do the [ __ ] baby out of a
cake what a lazy [ __ ] I'm with you all
yeah cuz I could do that cake you know I
mean you know what I like is that all of
this [ __ ] you put extra time into except
for the sprinkle pubic hair because just
sprinkle and also that good ice was not
even flesh color dude it's [ __ ] white
yeah this is a lazy cat like not worth
like talking [ __ ] about the bakery
because we've seen like some amazing
artwork yes was a stick a Snickers bar
stuck in that that'd be tight oh it
looks like that baby's taking a [ __ ] she
said the hardest part of the cake was
making the poop look realistic
it doesn't look realistic dude you did a
terrible job yeah buy a candy bar and
stuff it in there oh using like
strawberry jam get a brownie and roll it
up oh yeah yeah I should do that with
the fudge brownie yeah what the nuts in
it we would roll it up and in push the
Baker for seven years dude not long
enough
you need another 14 question
realistically how accurate is that photo
tours childbirth because that looks
painful
oh it's a clean section I don't know
it's a pretty accurate you didn't poop
though I didn't poo but a lot of people
do a lot of you poop and there's blood
everywhere yeah yeah it's a big ol mess
blood guts weird other bodily things
like you ever you ever open up a crab
when you open up a crab there's like
some tofu green [ __ ] you don't know what
the hell that [ __ ] is it's like that
there's just weird it just makes all
your guts come out what's I don't even
know if it does but it's like weird show
me why is the baby grab it
oh my god it's like the baby's getting
kicked out of his house trying to grab
everything
oh no grabbing a suitcase you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I did that I know I felt
like I cheated cuz I didn't do all that
I don't know we don't see you love it
maybe you didn't cheat on a regular all
I know is that when Mario's having that
baby I'm staying on the other side I'm
not watching I should come out I'm gonna
hold her hand and I'm screaming with her
yeah how do you get a hold her hand on
the other side no I'm not gonna I'm
gonna be next to her but nothing's gonna
be front he's gonna be in the waist up
yeah I don't know if I want to watch
either cuz I thought her [ __ ] [ __ ]
why not you made that happen
you know jerk want him to look at your
[ __ ] couch I didn't give a [ __ ] what
he looked at I was just like we're doing
this hold her hand and then look at her
face but her face isn't gonna be
pleasant either she's not gonna be like
this it's way better than no David on
this when I have a kid I want my man and
I to be sitting there holding each
other's hand staring at each other just
agree you are not gonna be staring at
your man I'm not looking down there
no you're do you don't even know where
you're looking your eyes are on the back
of your head cuz I hurt so much
I want to be able to see all that [ __ ] I
don't want to do this I'm gonna be
crying there's any smoke no I'm having
this conversation where I'm like yes
David you better look at it but my ass
does not even want to look at him yeah
exactly tell me well I was looking
everywhere else Carrie I just find it
amazing they let like a woman can push a
[ __ ] football off their [ __ ] and
then they're like you know what I'm
gonna do this again if a dude gets
kicked in the nuts one time he's like I
don't even want that to happen again the
women are like Oh like birth is so much
worse but it's like they continue we're
like yeah let's do that again and again
any one of our friends I think they
might have been Jess but they were like
I think it's biologically like embedded
in our minds to forget what I said that
video with you oh really so then we
could have more kids cuz then we kind of
like forget all my guys but also my
thing is people have been having babies
for how long huh couple hundred years
where the medical advances
where are the medical advances why yeah
there is a medical advance I didn't feel
[ __ ] I had such a pleasant birth
experience did it look anything like
that case because I find those
statements to be controversial probably
but the fact that I didn't feel anything
was dope uh but with wit so trip to me
is that there's all these advances right
yet there's a lot of women that are like
I'm gonna do it naturally
ya know yeah I'm like kudos to you but
you're not a home bro that said that
[ __ ] to her but her [ __ ] husband told
me she was like I want to do it napped
about the whole thing and they're right
when they paint it she gave me the
[ __ ] drugs like I need some drugs now
my cousin she [ __ ] crapped out at the
last minute oh your cousin - yeah that's
just so much buddy min cuz she did admit
it to anybody but he told me ya know
soon as my water breaks shoot me up doc
Wow
[Music]